NARRATOR: "Viking."
Derived from the old Norse term
"vikingr," generally referring
to Scandinavian men who
traveled, traded, and raided
through parts of Europe,
the Mediterranean,
Russia, and North America.
Men.
The standard history
popularized in the 19th century
tells us that only men
were Viking warriors.
But Norse mythology and now
science tell us differently.
History does teach us that Norse
women were much more liberated
than other women at the time.
They could own property,
conduct business, get a divorce,
and gain custody
of their children.
And Norse folklore and
mythology claim that women
were also fierce warriors.
Poems and stories
feature weapon wielding
women called shields maidens.
There were characters
like Freyd s Eir ksd ttir,
daughter of Norse
explorer Erik the Red,
who wielded a sword in battle
while eight months pregnant.
[screams]
Or Lagertha, who won over her
future husband Ragnar Lodbrok
with her fighting skills.
And the mythical Valkyries, who
wore armor and carried weapons
on the battlefield, choosing
which fighters would die
and ushering them into the grand
afterlife known as Valhalla.
But there was no hard proof that
great female Viking warriors
ever existed until
2017, which saw
the culmination of a
forensic investigation
that began in the 19th century.
In the 1980s, archaeologists
unearthed a well-preserved
and elaborately furnished
grave in the Viking trading
post of Birka, Sweden.
Alongside the body were
weapons and two horses.
On the lap was a chess-like
board game known as a king's
table, indicating
the grave inhabitant
was a commander that
made strategic decisions.
Based on these items,
scientists concluded
the burial site belonged to
a powerful military leader.
And by default, the body
was classified as male.
But no one checked the bones.
Over a century later, Stockholm
University osteologist Anna
Kjellstrom was analyzing
the Birka remains
for another study when she
noticed the pelvic bones
and mandible were feminine.
She estimated the bones belonged
to a woman over the age of 30
and approximately 5
foot 6 inches tall.
Kjellstrom published her
provocative findings in 2016,
which caused some controversy.
What?
NARRATOR: Since the Birka bones
were found over a century ago,
some argue they may
have been mislabeled
or possibly the bones of
several people mixed together.
But in 2017, another
woman stepped up
to answer the critics.
A research team led by
archaeologists Charlotte
Hedensterna-Jonson at
Sweden's Uppsala University
extracted two types
of DNA from the bones.
They confirmed
Kjellstrom's hypothesis.
The bones belonged to one woman.
In the findings, the
researchers concluded
that it was rare
to find evidence
of high ranking
female Viking warriors
not because they didn't
exist, but because of sexism
in scientific research.
Though some Viking women
buried with weapons are known,
a female warrior
of this importance
has never been determined,
and Viking scholars
have been reluctant to
acknowledge the agency of women
with weapons.